hi everyone and thank you for having me
thank you to the organizers for making
this possible kinds of introduction just
by way of adding a little bit more of
context my PhD was really looking at
human behavior physical environment
relationships so really the interaction
effects between people and place and so
that's also a way of thinking about
geography I when thinking about this
this dark and what I could offer from my
perspective as a practicing planner an
activist planner in an institution like
hunter I started to think about that I
could probably help situate open data
open knowledge open gif in the context
of thinking about spatial citizenship
it's a term that has been used in the
literature it's not particularly new but
probably trying to to build traction for
that terminology here and see if we can
establish some connections between open
GIS and spatial citizenship and really
took to heart the panelists charge which
was to you know how do we achieve this
truly open GIS or then I started
thinking about is it open GIS or is it
to be open with GIS oh it's catch the
classic tool science conundrum that we
keep talking about in the GIS world so
as I'm an educator I work with I prepare
practicing planners I'm a researcher I
work with communities that are often
marginalized for one reason or the other
and so from that perspective looking at
the lens with that lens looking at this
landscape of what comes under the
umbrella of
open GIS or open planning the landscape
is very crowded it seems almost daunting
for an for an outsider to look at this
landscape so you have industry you have
the scientific community you certainly
have the activist community everybody is
sort of putting their mark on on what it
means to be open and do research in this
way and this is a screen grab from City
fixer and open is everywhere so I'm a
practicing planner I'm preparing experts
who are put on food experts and planning
but this is everybody's a planner so
there's a little tension here about what
happens when we use open G is that
because it empowers a whole bunch of
people to to have positions and
interventions about the city that we
live in so you are probably familiar
with these these concepts and
terminologies but from is just to think
about you can't get anywhere in this
this day and age without hearing big
data thrown in it almost is sort of de
rigueur to have the those phrase big
data and they've been occasional
critiques of what big data is and the
limits of big data for the kinds of
problems that we're trying to solve but
essentially we are really moving into a
highly data-driven geography work that
has frozen content assume that will
address them in the discussion but in
the end it comes back to what you said
like you know technology for the common
good that the you know it's sort of
these cliches you know don't do evil or
do technology for good and you
immediately have to ask good for whom
good for what and without that it's
really not very helpful but yet that's
what we hear in
everywhere so I said to you that I was
looking at people place relationships so
most of my thinking is really about this
how do we as as human beings and
gatherings of human beings with and with
the help of technologies transform the
world we live in and we all have
examples by which we do this on a
day-to-day basis but it seems to me this
week in particular considering all the
events that have occurred we probably
want to think about sort of those pesky
issues that have been there from the
beginning right access to information
who has access who doesn't have access
and how quickly that access can be taken
away because any and the same argument
about privacy this is a conversation
worldwide going on right now about what
our right to privacy is really and
particularly geospatial in geospatial
privacy and then the ethics of using
this approach the data-driven approach
to decision making and and sort of in
the public interest but really who
defines what that public interest is and
so I put it to you very bluntly I asked
you who has the power and so I make this
list which I try to make it in terms of
a hierarchy and you so going from most
power to lease power and some of you
might look at this and say hey you got
the order all wrong because really you
know you put universities in there about
super PACs is can that be and we can
quibble about where each one is on this
hierarchy but there's some people who
are not even they didn't even make it to
the list right and so the people who
don't have formal
who don't have skills aren't even on
this list so then and I say power I
don't just mean money power money powers
really important but there's
infrastructure power is computing power
there's data power they staffing like
you know technical support power and in
that context we are not really engaging
very carefully about the large to other
people who are not on this list as a
community of scholars and educators and
and activists so when I move on to think
about you know how we are creating
knowledge how we are producing knowledge
and how we are using knowledge at least
in my field which is planning we have
moved from doing planning which is a
very normative future-oriented set of
goals to being managers and nothing
wrong with being managers you need good
managers but management of cities is
very different from planning of cities
and and there's a tension there which we
are glossing over right now because if
you talk to the Big Data folks and if
you talk to the the people who are using
let's come to open in a minute but let
you get are you talking about big data
and how would you sister cities it's all
about just in time real-time decision
making solving problems on the fly and I
occasionally introduce questions about
causality and I get shot down right away
and yeah it's an answer usually is you
don't need to worry about causality or
causal chains correlations good enough
to get the job done and and for
management purposes yes that in some
sense that the correlation is what all
that we may mean but it seems to me that
we are
missing out some huge opportunities in
not asking these difficult questions as
a bigger community I think the
conversations are happening but they are
very siloed so I did my own Yelp version
of what what I think is going on totally
this is a Laxmi's view of the world and
you know welcome to argue with me about
it so I think that you know why why do
we care about open data why do we care
about open G is open knowledge because
we want to to address those larger
societal rules of democratizing
decision-making presume we're not doing
it just for the the sake of doing it we
see there's a causal link there so how
we doing and I think we're doing pretty
well on data access although we can
quibble about this because you go back
to a data that used to be open is no
longer open data that used to be free is
no longer free it keeps changing I can't
rely on things always being accessible
and it happened post 911 I have no idea
what's going to happen now but
essentially there's a change that that
happens as geopolitics changes
information access data is data
synthesize information is accessible if
you know how to make sense of the
information that's being presented to
you I think there's great opportunities
for dialogue we come together this
different forums and I think we're doing
very well on individual empowerment
right and that is the commercial angle
to all of this that that you as an
individual are very empowered because
you have access to all of this
information and data like that you can
then use in your own
and perhaps you know my co-panelists
we'll talk some about that think we're
not doing very well on Kruk empowerment
that you know we're not really doing
well on using the open data the open
knowledge to actually deal with
structural problems socio-political
problems we're not doing well in we are
reactive we are not so again it's just a
tension-free planning and management we
are reactive rather than being proactive
so let me give it a little bit if next
set of ideas is really related to
citizenship and so if you do a simple
word cloud you come up with these terms
that relate to critical thinking and
reasoning because in order to be a
facial citizen you you have to have
motivation to to use these technologies
to participate to actually again to
bring this idea of participating in
democratic processes so I started to
think about what are the components what
are the framework elements that would
allow you to participate so then if you
look at these individual frames like
methodological competency technical
competency communication competency or
situational assessment competency then
you start to think what should we be
doing and I mean I'm in the education
sector what should I be doing as an
educator to prepare my students to
achieve these competencies and what is
what are what is the open G is community
doing to help me address these goals and
I think they are doing a great deal but
really that's a continuing question and
move over this i think there are
benefits that are quite clear that we
are do i think others argue that if
you're special citizen you're more
engaged
you are able to solve problems in an in
a collaborative way but that it also
allows for those folks who are building
tools and processes to customize and
deliver supportive infrastructure that
is respectful of local knowledge so I
will tell you that if in terms of where
we want to be I think that you need open
G is open data open knowledge as well as
preparing spatial citizens which are
sort of two different things in order to
achieve the promise that open GIS is
offering so that's kind of my take-home
message really that I'm glad that the
open G has communities come together and
doing all these things but that by
itself is not going to achieve a
long-term goal so maybe I can come later
for talking about i have discussion
implications for research for education
and for practice but perhaps i will save
that for the discussion part of the top
thank you
[Applause]